[Music]
In summary, behind the court, the proven
facts are declared so serious and the
consequences are so
great that it is only the
heaviest possible prison sentence and
appropriate punishment in this case to retaliate
for what the suspect has done and
with which so much suffering has been inflicted yes
so many victims and next of kin
and I know They won't go to jail but uh
the world no Who is responsebol for the
devil flight amateur When I country is
a responsible for
facilitating the shooting Down over
AirPlay het kan be so that I can get
away  with it and they have to Be Held eh
accountable in public en That's What
happened today
[Music]